bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous alors cette élection de
joe biden à ce qu'elles peuvent vraiment
changer la donne pour boris johnson oui
probablement et pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que lorsque le
président élu s'installera à la maison
blanche
il y aura une sorte de changement de
logiciel puisque donald trump étaient
propres excite au gorille johnson et
qu'il lui avait promis à un accord de
libre échange sur mesure avec les états
unis
d'ailleurs ce qu'il n'a pas fait puisque
les anglais ont constaté que les
américains allaient être des partenaires
difficiles là le dante donc avec ce
nouveau logiciel
effectivement cela signifie que les
états unis se montrent plus favorable je
baille donne que votre sujet l'a
expliqué était à l'origine style au
mexique et il considère que en effet
l'union européenne est un élément de
stabilité en europe et d'autre part de
façon un peu plus cynique il considère
que pour les intérêts américains
il était mieux défendu lorsque la
grande-bretagne était dedans qu'avec une
grande bretagne à l'extérieur cela dit
joe biden a montré son attachement à ce
qu'on appelle l'accord du vendredi saint
c'est à dire un accord entre toutes les
parties prenantes et tous les partis
politiques d'irlande du nord et de la
république d'irlande pour mettre une fin
à 30 ans de guerre civile qui a fait
plus de 3500 morts
donc à partir de ce moment là on a
appris des décisions qui porte les
institutions mais aussi avec l'aide de
l'union européenne et bien la
suppression de toutes frontières
physiques entre l'irlande du nord qui
appartient au royaume uni et la
république d'irlande qui continue de
faire partie de l'union européenne donc
joe biden a dit très clairement qu' il
ne pouvait pas concevoir que cet accord
soit mis en difficulté et que
lire on court le risque de voir revenir
une frontière ne serait ce que 2 paniers
entre l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande
il a été très clair il a même dit que
dans ce cas il n'y aurait pas de
possibilité d'accords de libre échange
entre les états unis et la grande
bretagne alors en claude y at il
d'autres facteurs qui poussent le
premier ministre est à nîmes dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
oui alors monsieur boris johnson a
quelques difficultés avec le parlement
de westminster et cette semaine il est
très probable dit on que la chambre dès
lors rejette son projet de loi qui est
ce projet de loi pour garantir à un
marché unique fluide entre la grande
bretagne et l'irlande du nord et ceux ci
qui est le risque serait ce ce texte de
loi risqueraient de venir contredire la
nex irlande précisément du traité de
sortie de l'union européenne du traité
qui a été ratifiée à la fin de l'année
dernière tous les anciens premiers
ministres britanniques vivant se sont
d'ailleurs opposés à ce traité et à la
remise en cause de la parole donnée par
le royaume uni le fait d'avoir un accord
de libre échange permettrait
probablement de résoudre assez largement
cette difficulté
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième c'est que la grande bretagne
connaît actuellement une crise
économique très importante du fait de la
pandémie
on prévoit que son pnb rabaissée de 10 %
environ cette année
et donc ces problèmes en pas le moment
d'ajouter la crise à la crise et
d'ajouter tous les inconvénients
économiques de la sortie du de la sortie
de l'union douanière sens libre échange
à cette crise qui découle de la pandémie
cela dit effectivement boris johnson a
s'est fixé lui-même une ligne une ligne
rouge
qui est la défense de la souveraineté du
royaume uni il n'acceptera pas de faire
des concessions sur un sujet qui touche
à la souveraineté
qu'il s'agisse de l'aide aux entreprises
où il s'agisse de la pêche alors que
l'aube blanche maison évidemment la
question tout le monde se pose telle
issue un accord ou pas d'accord alors on
a bien vu que ce week-end une sorte de
lueur d'espoir apparaît pour qu'il y ait
un accord
c'est d'ailleurs les mots de de boris
johnson qui dit on voit bien les lignes
se sont qualifiés hier matin il faut
passer à l'acte et c'est un peu aussi ce
que dit ursula von der leyen en étant
plus réaliste en dix ans on a fait des
progrès mais il reste était accord très
important
alors d'abord je crois qu'on peut dire
que sur les trois points principaux le
premier sur le premier point la sagesse
a prévalu et donc on l'a probablement
trouver un compromis sur la gouvernance
des rapports du régime futur entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni à
savoir que s'il ya des différends et
bien il y aura des tribunaux mixtes et
les commissions mixtes qui trancheront
c'est différent ce ne sont pas des
organes de l'union européenne et c'est
ce que voulait en effet la grande
bretagne mais c'est aussi acceptable par
l'union européenne le deuxième point
c'est la libre circulation des produits
des produits britanniques fabriqué en
grande bretagne sur le territoire de
l'union européenne et l'union européenne
évidemment veut vérifier que il n'ya pas
de dumping social qu'il n'ya pas d'un
ping environnementale et que le
gouvernement britannique où les
gouvernements des deux cô te donne pas
des subventions a dû à ces produits là
on est encore loin d'un accord mais il
est possible que boris johnson
choisissent de sortir par le haut en
disant que bien entendu il n'est pas
question de réduire le niveau de
protection sociale en grande bretagne il
n'est pas question non plus de brader et
et r
respect de l'environnement les critères
écologiques et par conséquent peu trop
long pourrait trouver une formule
d'assurance des mots font plein de
respect de ses critères
merci avant que la pêche effectivement
le problème reste très largement ouvert
mais il est possible de trouver un
compromis si on le veut et on verra on
sera ça cette semaine la bourse
aujourd'hui à monthey
alors comme à paris et et on verra quels
sont les mouvements l'aspect dans les
prochains jours merci à vous lance
maison